liberal priorities seem to be getting
more unrealistic if you can believe that
New York Governor Kathy hokel signing a
bill creating a task force to consider
race-based reparations and she was even
joined by Al Sharpton at the bill
signing ceremony on the right side of
this you know slavery was a product of
the South it's the Confederacy we're the
heroes we're the ones who fought against
slavery what is hard to
embrace is the fact that our state also
flourished from that
slavery it's not a beautiful story but
indeed it is the truth and I want to
give credit to this governor for having
the audacity and courage and I know her
political advisors told her it's too
risky but she did it because it's right
so you may remember the last time a big
blue State tried to do this California
had a similar task force that
recommended payment of as much as 1.2
million per eligible resident that went
nowhere with Governor Gavin Nome casting
doubt on it and Greg it's almost as if
Governor hokel is saying let me give
very serious consideration to something
I will never actually have to deal with
exactly I mean I I often say she's
stupid and she is but this is a
brilliant move this is why companies
have town halls and stores have ideas
boxes and schools have parent nights you
pretend you care like you're gonna act
and then you do nothing because it
already looks like you did something
this is why Nome is a pro he saw this as
ludicrous and he knew the conclusions
that they would come up with would be so
patly absurd that they would be
laughable I think it came down to like
$2 million a person impossible to trace
so she said hey create a working tax
Force you get you you'll get your bottle
of water Al sharp don't will get his
little Place in the Sun you know you'll
have your breakfast is paid for and and
then that'll go on for a month and then
they'll get the ridiculous proposal and
then she'll just put it away somewhere I
do this whenever Jesse asks me to go to
lunch I go awesome I go get me a list
get me a list of restaurants you want to
go to and dates and you know we we can
pick a time and blah blah blah blah blah
blah instead of saying great cuz then he
goes to work and then he just gives up
we've never eaten lunch together exactly
T clothes maybe that could be your New
Year's resolution I want lunch
reparations what do you think of this
why what happened in California is going
to happen here it's going to be a waste
of time they spent six months wasting
time at these hearings where these
politicians could have been doing
something on homelessness or drugs or
crime and at the end of the day they go
like this and they kick it down the road
and they get credit for trying but they
didn't really try because they were just
banging their head against the wall same
thing's going to happen here going see
crime go up homelessness go up Subway
crime go up but they're going to get
credit and hok's going to get credit and
Al's going to look like he's in the
spotlight and then everybody's not going
to get paid how about you just work oh
my gosh how about you just earn a living
instead of waiting around for a handout
that's never going to happen har by the
way can I just say if we're going to
dwell in the past which is what the
Democrats love to do rather than deal
with the present then we have every
right to bring up Al Sharpton's past if
he's going to talk about reparations
let's talk about toana broy huh have you
has he ever paid out for that stuff
where are the reparations for all those
people falsely
accused Harold are we missing anything I
don't know I I I I tend to agree with
not the last point I like Al Sharpton a
lot but the point you you and I talked
about this before in the show he's a
dear friend you and I've talked about it
for the remedy to these things probably
shouldn't be the things that California
and economic we should be trying to
guarantee education and guarantee some
sort of to the extent we can some sort
of opportunity because the fundamental
question and I think all of us can
appreciate this but I think about
everything kind of an illegal framework
what is the remedy for a 100 Years of
Slavery followed by less than seven
years or 10 years of reconstruction uh
that was ended with a with with a uh
with a
basically an agreement that said look
we'll stop trying to do these things I
don't know if I know the answer to it
but I'm not sure what I do know is I'm
not sure we actually gave a remedy take
the race out of it if blacks had done
this to whites um 100 Years of more of
slavery uh Jim Crow segregation are we
doing this the right way I just think
that that's that's the question I don't
disagree with what we way we've talked
about is this going to happen is this a
waste of time should we be focused on
other things you and I've talked on the
show before um the kids who are often
times black and brown often times are in
schools that just aren't
should we be doing more there we can
debate those kind of Remedies now we'll
say this uh if there is going to be a
monetary remedy I want them to have my
correct address so I will make sure that
I send that uh wherever you tell me to
send it
very that's a good Emily multiple
opportunities Connecticut soon to have a
commission to study reparations yeah and
you know to to that point investment
versus payment legally speaking repar a
ends any type of grievance so if let's
just say hypothetically reparations was
supposed to take place legally speaking
it completely concludes any type of
grievance so therefore there would could
be after this then no affirmative action
no anything no other programs because
you have been made equal in the eyes of
the law and been restored so how much
you know what enough is enough because
there's a whole host of issues that you
can't qualify in monetary um means in
terms of the generational impact and
horrible atrocity but if blacks had done
this to whites for 100 years I just want
everybody to think about it because we
we get we we get so fixated and
intoxicated thinking about the Race part
but this is just slavery this is just a
this is just with the Japanese I don't
mean to interrupt your time take your
time that it's a great Point um but but
I have to say that to me the theatrics
of this are the most unpalatable because
we all know that the conversation about
reparations is robust and important but
in Practical terms it's never going to
happen the state is falling apart I can
attest to it because I live here this
city is falling apart and to have the
governor stand next to Al Sharpton who
called Whitney Houston Whitey Houston
because her music wasn't black enough
which I still remember and to have this
governor who just recently despite her
legislature passing five times to
recognize the Monet tribe on Long Island
as an actual federally recognized tribe
she says oh no sorry not today during
Native American History Month when they
have provided so much evidence and she
said nope the 1910 decision still stands
where it called them shiftless is
disgusting and to me the point is it's
because Native Americans to her the
indigenous tribes to her they're not
cool enough yet right they haven't risen
enough on on the poles or on her
barometer for her to actually care so
for her to stand there and pretends that
she cares about black people here she
doesn't care about people of color she
doesn't care about any underserved
Community she cares about herself in the
polls and whatever she thinks will get
her enough to Virtue signal that's the
only can I just Harold if if your
grandfather was a Union soldier and died
fighting in the Civil War to free slaves
I would think that's enough reparations
my grandfather my great-grandfather died
fighting that war just take this offline
we'll take it offine okay we're going to
take it offline hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else